China's government may have the personal
information of nearly half of all
Americans think about that for a second
according to the Justice Department
four members of the country's military
are charged with allegedly stealing
information from about 145 million
people in this country new 2017 breach
of the credit monitoring firm Equifax
now China denies all of these charges
our consumer investigative correspondent
that's Anna Warner is here and a good
morning to you how in the world did this
happen
great question Gail good morning
investigators say the hackers had access
to Equifax as computer systems for
months stealing millions of Americans
personal information until now it wasn't
clear who might have stolen the data and
it still isn't clear what it might be
used for this was one of the largest
data breaches in history Attorney
General William Barr says four Chinese
military hackers are charged with
computer fraud economic espionage and
wire fraud for allegedly hacking Equifax
as computer systems in 2017 according to
the indictment the hackers obtained the
names birth dates and social security
numbers of nearly 150 million Americans
they also targeted people's driver's
license and credit card numbers our
cases reveal a pattern of
state-sponsored computer intrusions and
thefts by China targeting trade secrets
and confidential business information
the DOJ says there isn't evidence that
the information stolen from Equifax is
being used at this time but Alan Butler
with the Electronic Privacy Information
Center says that might not be the case
for long there's no assurance that the
use of this data is going to be you know
limited to the Chinese military it very
well could end up on the black market he
notes the problems that Equifax occurred
after the company failed to patch a
known vulnerability in a software
program a vulnerability the hacker is
exploited companies are collecting far
too much data they're not storing it
securely and frankly we don't have a
legal regime in the United States that
addresses the types and vast quantities
of data that these companies are
collecting in a statement Equifax said
over the past two years they've made
significant progress and investments to
protect
data entrusted to us now the Justice
Department says 80% of its economic
Espionage prosecutions have implicated
the Chinese government as always experts
recommend that you consumers all of us
freeze and monitor your credit so you
got to freeze those three accounts with
it it's an ongoing question how to keep
your information safe it really it's all
right Anna thanks